foreign
[Music]
I'm so pleased to be here today to speak
to you about the vaginal microbiome and
susceptibility to urogenital infections
these are my disclosures and
acknowledgments and I did want to take a
moment uh to pause and say that we're
discussing the vaginal microbiome today
but of course uh not all people with
vaginas and hence a vaginal microbiome
will identify as women and I'll try to
be as mindful as possible of that but if
I use CIS women's Centric language it's
either for clarity for ease of
discussion or because of the language
used in the research cited and truly it
is not intended as an Erasure for other
important demographics
so our objectives by the end of this
presentation
um you'll be able to identify the basic
elements of the vaginal microbiota
Identify some ways in which possibly the
vaginal microbiota may protect against
acquisition of sexually transmitted and
urogenital infections in women and
identify some challenges in developing
novel microbiome
improve women's reproductive Health this
is going to be sort of a very broad
overview talk I'm just touching lightly
on some of these subjects but I hope
you'll find it interesting
so uh
today we're going to talk about the
vaginal microbiome um and so that's a
little bit about what we mean by that
um so when I talk today about the
vaginal microbiome or microbiota I
really mean the communities of bacteria
inhabiting the vagina now as you know
our bodies are covered with bacteria um
there's specialized communities living
in each anatomic area that are adapted
especially for that Niche and the vagina
is no exception
I think it's really remarkable that in
the last 20 years or so we've realized
that some of these bacteria that are
living on us can cause harm and can
cause disease but others may actually be
critical to our health really
interesting concept and one that
definitely applies to the vaginal
microbiome now I'll pause and just say
that of course uh technically microbiota
refers to the microbial species present
in a community whereas microbiome refers
to the microbial Gene repertoire but
I'll use those interchangeably today
again really to reference the
communities of bacteria in this case
inhabiting the vagina
now another note we're going to be
focusing on the bacteria today because
that's really where most of the research
has occurred but keep in mind they're
not the only ones that are there there
is a virum a microbiome so fungi that
might be present in that location even a
paracetome and those are very important
emerging areas of research but as I said
most of the work to date has been done
on bacteria and that'll be our Focus
today
so what is the importance of the vaginal
microbiota or microbiome well we think
it's very important because in the
healthier optimal State we think of the
vaginal microbiota as the body's first
line of defense against invading
pathogens and so an optimal or healthy
vaginal microbiome we think is dominated
by a few lactobacillus species which as
their name suggests produce something
called lactic acid that acidifies the
vaginal pH and is very protective
against things that might like to invade
like gonorrhea or chlamydia or even E
coli
um this is an image up here to the right
of these nice long rods lactobacilli on
top of a vaginal epithelial cell and
there are a number of mechanisms by
which lactobacilli may act to prevent
infection with some of these these
pathogens that we'll discuss later in
the talk
now in some women for reasons that are
incompletely understood those vaginal
lactobacilli are decreased and instead
there's an overgrowth of a variety of
gram negatives and anaerobes things like
gardnerella vaginalis prevotella mobile
unkus smithia adipium Etc and these
individuals have lower lactic acid in
the vagina and an elevated vaginal pH
and that condition that low
lactobacillus condition is called
bacterial vaginosis or BV
now about 50 percent of women with this
low lactobacillus State this bacterial
vaginosis are symptomatic and
symptomatic BV is in fact the leading
cause of vaginal complaints in women of
reproductive age in the United States
women classically complain of vaginal
odor or discharge though they may have
some other symptoms and clinically uh BV
is diagnosed via the amsil's criteria so
if a woman comes into a doctor
complaining of things like vaginal odor
or discharge the doctor will do a pelvic
exam look at the vagina and diagnose her
with BV if she meets three out of the
four amsil's criteria and those are
having a thin homogeneous vaginal
discharge so a characteristic discharge
an elevated vaginal pH
clue cells which are vaginal epithelial
cells that are covered by a mat of BB
Associated bacteria and you can see a
clue cell on top of a normal vaginal
epithelial cell in the image here on the
slide
and then having a positive amine or with
test we're essentially Koh is added to
vaginal secretions and produces a
fishier or amine odor and so clinically
in symptomatic women BV is diagnosed via
the amsilos criteria for research
purposes for many years we've used
something called the Nugent score which
essentially quantifies different
morphologies of bacteria present on a
Gram stain and essentially estimates
What proportion of those are those
healthy optimal lactobacilli as compared
to the bv-associated bacteria
more recently there have been some
molecular tests that have become
available including some
microbiome-based tests that essentially
quantify based on sequencing how much
lactobacilli as compared to some of
these BV Associated bacteria are present
in the vaginal microbiome
now I think some it's really interesting
about bacterial vaginosis or BV is that
it really is we think a disorder of the
vaginal microbiota and if you think
about it we hear a lot about the
microbiome but there are very few
diseases that we can identify as a
disorder or dysbiosis or messing up of
the microbiome perhaps you could say
that C diff diarrhea is one of those but
this is really the most clear example I
can think of and I think as a prototype
entity it's very interesting from that
perspective
now in the last 15 years or so
um with the Advent of new molecular
techniques things like 16s RNA Gene
applicant sequencing metagenomics
Etc we've really developed a more
in-depth knowledge about the vaginal
microbiome and bacterial vaginosis and
many of the bacteria that are present in
the vaginal microbiome are anaerobes so
they're very difficult to culture these
sequencing techniques have really
enabled us to identify the full depth
and breadth and complexity of these
communities that inhabit the vagina
so what we know now from these new
techniques is that the vaginal
microbiome of at least reproductive age
women can be categorized into a number
of different Community to State types or
csts
based on composition and relative
abundance and four of those are
dominated by lactobacilli of different
kinds
um the last or cst4 is a low
lactobacillus essentially bv-like State
that's dominated by a variety of
bv-associated bacteria
and enabling this sort of uh more
specific characterization of the
microbiome has really enabled us to make
some uh import to have some important
insights as well I think the first of
those is that bacterial vaginosis is not
monolithic it's not that all women with
BV have exactly the same vaginal
microbiome so uh cst4 that bv-like state
is commonly grouped at least into two
and sometimes three different
subcategories depending upon which
bacteria are there so it's not that all
women with BV have exactly the same
microbiome and that might be important
in the long term in thinking about how
we treat baby
now
in terms of other important insights uh
We've recently with these new molecular
techniques been able to identify
lactobacilli down to the species level
um and so I think that's important
because what it's allowed us to do is
then relate those species level
associations to outcomes such as an
increased risk of acquisition of STIs
and our old Paradigm was essentially
that lactobacilli are good and BB
Associated bacteria are bad because
lactobacilli are associated with
protection from STIs and other bad
outcomes whereas beefy is associated
with an increased risk of acquisition of
STIs and other infections but I think
with this new identification now we've
started to make these associations with
more nuance and what we're starting to
see is not all lactobacilli are equally
protective so we'll talk about this more
in a little while but lactobacillus
inners in particular appears to be less
protective than lactobacillus crespitis
um in uh in uh protecting against
acquisition of STIs
now the vaginal microbiome uh differs
throughout life and there are some
important things that influence the
vaginal microbiome one that I wanted to
highlight is the role of hormones so
before menarchy uh before girls have
much in the way of estrogen lactobacilli
are low but as women go through menarchy
and are in their reproductive years
estrogen levels are high and
lactobacilli increases well so estrogen
really supports the growth of
lactobacilli in the vaginal microbiome
then in menopause levels of estrogen
decrease and lactobacilli decrease as
well
even within a menstrual cycle the
hormones can influence the vaginal
microbiome so for instance this is a
study which shows that when levels of
estrogen are high in the red line here
in the middle of the cycle the vaginal
microbiome is more stable than at times
when estrogen is low and particularly
more stable than at times of Menses
where we think that blood in the vaginal
Vault also acts to destabilize the
vaginal microbiome
now I talked a little bit about this
question of whether all lactobacilli are
created equal and what their protective
properties may be against STIs and we
think a lot of that might have to do
with the lactic acid that they produce
so lactobacillus crispatis dominated
vaginal microbiome tend to produce a lot
of lactic acid and have a very low PH so
this these Green Dots here are vaginal
microbiota dominated by lactobacillus
grosspotis and they're colored green
because the vaginal pH is very low less
than 4.5
lactobacillus energy is dominated
vaginal microbiota on the other hand
sometimes have a low PH but sometimes
have a much higher pH and we know that
lactobacillus inners is not as good at
producing lactic acid then that diverse
BV group in the middle there cst4 tends
to have very high pH because there's
very little lactic acid
but the story may be even a little more
complicated than that it may not just
acid but it may in fact be particular
isomers of lactic acid there that are
important and so there are two isomers
of lactic acid d-lactic and lactate that
are produced by some lactobacilli
lactobacillus crespitis here you can see
is very good at producing d-lactate in
the red as well as l-lactate in the blue
whereas lactobacillus inners essentially
doesn't produce D lactate at all though
it can produce some l-lactate so keep
that in mind as we talk about mechanisms
later on in the presentation
now we'll talk about a number of
different STIs including chlamydia and
gonorrhea which are the number one and
number two most commonly reported STIs
in the United States
um these are very uh common
unfortunately particularly in younger
women they're usually asymptomatic but
women can have vaginal discharge pain
with urination or non-specific symptoms
they can cause a serviceitis or
infection of the cervix and this picture
at the top right here is a very infected
inflamed cervix that's red and has pus
essentially
on an untreated both gonorrhea and
chlamydia can lead to pelvic
inflammatory disease infertility and
chronic pelvic pain
trichomonas is another important STI
it's actually the most common non-viral
STI in the United States it's caused by
a parasite it's commonly asymptomatic
but it can cause a vaginal infection
with vaginal itching irritation pain
with urination discharge and odor and
classically on exam a clinician can see
what's called a strawberry cervix which
is a cervix here in the picture at the
lower right hand corner of the slide
that has these punctate red hemorrhagic
areas
another STI we'll discuss in the
upcoming slides is uh human papilloma
virus
um that is HPV which causes uh uh
service it causes cervical cancer as
well as genital warts
um and that is actually the most
prevalent as STI in the United States
so let's talk about some of the
associations that really is the focus of
this talk
um so this is a meta-analysis uh where a
group looked at associations in a number
of different studies between having a
low lactobacillus vaginal microbiota I.E
that bv-like or dysbiotic state with
having a gonorrhea infection whether
incident or prevalence and they found a
trend towards an association between an
increased risk of gonorrhea if you had a
low lactobacillus or bv-like state I'll
say that there have been a couple of
large epidemiologic studies that came
out since this one was since this
meta-analysis was done that showed even
more strongly that there is a link
between having a low lactobacillus
vaginal microbiota iebv and having an
increased risk of incident gonococcal
in so really this risk of Gonorrhea
acquisition with having a dysbiotic
vaginal microbiome
similarly with HPV human papillomavirus
which as we mentioned causes cervical
cancer as well as genital aborts there
is an increased risk of prevalent HPV
infection in those who have BV as
compared with the lactobacillus
dominated vaginal microbiota as well as
an increased risk of the HPV persisting
and not going away not being cleared and
that's important because persistent HPV
is more likely to lead to cervical
cancer
very similar Association we see between
having a low lactobacillus vaginal
microbiota and increased risk of
incidence and prevalent trichomonas
infection that parasitic infection we
talked about
and lastly there's a strong association
between having a low lactobacillus
vaginal microbiota iebv and having
incident or prevalent chlamydia
infection
now I mentioned that we certainly see
this association between having a
bv-like state and an increased risk of
acquiring chlamydia but what about
l-ners I had started to talk about we're
having some indications that that one
may not be as protective as some of the
other lactobacilli and so there were a
couple of studies one done by vanderveer
which came out in 2017 and one done by
Van hoot which came out in 2018
which looked at the risk of chlamydia
acquisition in those who had a low
lactobacill estate and El crispatus
dominated State and an L interdominated
state
and so vanderveer for example they were
looking at women who were contacts to
individuals diagnosed with chlamydia and
looking to see who actually acquired it
who tested positive for chlamydia and
they found that those who had a low
lactobacillus or BV like vaginal
microbiome were at an increased risk of
chlamydia as compared to those who had a
lactobacillus crespitis dominated state
with an odds ratio of about 4.2
but intriguingly they also found that
those who had L inners were at an
increased risk as compared to those who
had El crispatus dominating their
vaginal microbiome for chlamydia
infection with an odds ratio of about
4.4 so very interesting on and those uh
results were similar in the van hoot
study showing that we see an association
between an increased risk of acquiring
many of these STIs and having a low
lactobacill estate
but also lactobacillus inners in
particular may not be as protective as
lactobacillus respatus
what are the mechanisms here well this
is an area which I think it needs a lot
more research this is all very
preliminary but we do think that lactic
acid may play an important role so there
are a number of studies including one
I'll show you on the next slide which
suggests that at least in vitro lactic
acid can inhibit the growth of things
like gonorrhea or chlamydia or their
infectivity and that low ph is critical
here too
Also lactobacilli may bind very tightly
to vaginal epithelial cells and through
competitive binding prevent The Binding
of things like trichomonas or gonorrhea
and prevent them from establishing a
foothold in the vagina and causing
infection
immunomodulation might be important we
know that lactobacilli tend to Tamp down
inflammation in the vaginal
microenvironment and protect perhaps
that results in better barrier
epithelial Integrity that prevents
infection we don't know for sure though
and then there are metabolites other
than lactic acid that may be important
as well so chlamydia trachomatis
requires tryptophan for its growth and
it has to acquire that from the host
cell so one of the key defenses against
chlamydia is that the host cell is
capable of depleting tryptophan and
essentially starving chlamydia of this
very important factor but in vitro
studies at least have shown that certain
BV Associated bacteria certain strains
of prevotella in particular can produce
a substance called indole that chlamydia
is capable of turning back into
tryptophan and can actually rescue the
growth of chlamydia and promote
chlamydia persistence so perhaps some
metabolites produced by BV Associated
bacteria may actually
enhance susceptibility to or Persistence
of infection
this is another study that I mentioned
uh looking at the role of lactic acid in
this case for chlamydia they did in
vitro chlamydia trachomatis uh secondary
infection assays and they essentially
incubated cells with the supernatants
from uh cultures of lactobacillus
crispatus and the orange on the right
here lactobacillus jenseni and the
yellow and lactobacillus inners and
light orange all here on the right and
then did this chlamydia infectivity
assay at zero hours 24 hours and 48
hours and what they found that there was
that there was significant inhibition of
chlamydia infectivity in those
experiments where the cells have been
incubated with a super supernatant from
lactobacillus crespitis and jenseni that
effect was definitely not as strong well
vacillus inners and then they tried to
tease out whether that was due to lactic
acid or not and so they did similar
assays where they incubated at the cells
either with the control in the light
gray or with d lactic acid in the dark
blue lactic acid in the pink or HCL so
just hydrochloric acid to see if it's
just a pH effect on the purple and then
they did the assays again at 0 24 and 48
hours and what they found was that there
was definitely uh increased inhibition
of chlamydia trachomatis infectivity
over the control when using d-lactate to
a lesser extent lactate and really
almost not at all with HCL
though that effect was somewhat
attenuated with a longer time
particularly in the 48 hour time frame
so lactic acid seems to be very
important here
HIV we've actually known for a long time
that BV is associated with an increased
risk of HIV acquisition this is a
meta-analysis done as far back as 2008
which showed that women with BV had an
increased risk of both incident and
prevalent HIV
some of those Studies have now begun to
be replicated in the era of new
molecular
assays and so this was a study done by
Gossman where they followed a very high
risk cohort of women in South Africa
just to see which women acquired HIV and
which did not and track their vaginal
microbiota tried to related to that HIV
acquisition outcome and what they saw
was that women with a bv-like state so
low in lactobacillus in this case they
said their Community State types were
ct3 and four had an increased risk of
acquiring HIV a significant increased
risk of acquiring HIV over those who had
a lactobacillus respondus dominated
State
um they did find that some women with
lactobacillus inners had did acquire HIV
though at a lower rate than those who
had BV and remarkably not a single woman
with lactobacillus crespitis dominated
vaginal microbiota in this entire study
acquired HIV so really an amazing using
a sort of protective effect that was
seen there
what are the mechanisms again these are
understudy but lactic acid certainly in
vitro has been shown to inhibit HIV
activity and we think that inflammation
may be very important here as well so
activated CD4 T cells that Express the
HIV co-receptor ccr5 are more prone to
infection and there are certain
inflammatory or pro-inflammatory
cytokines and chemokines in the vaginal
microenvironment that have been
associated with HIV acquisition things
like il1 alpha tnf alpha
Etc and again the Gossman paper showed
very clearly that women who had a
bv-like state that ct3 and 4 had
increased levels in the vagina of
certain pro-inflammatory cytokines and
chemokines things like il1 alpha tnf
alpha and some others that have been
associated with HIV acquisition so maybe
inflammation is very important in
mediating this relationship with HIV
lastly just to uh end what about urinary
tract infections in women well I would
say this is much less studied the
association with the vaginal microbiome
and susceptibility is much less studied
um but it is an interesting area of
emerging research and urinary tract
infections are certainly an enormous
problem in women
um they are the most common bacterial
infection and uh post-menopausal women
in particular are disproportionately
impacted many of them experiencing
chronic recurrent UTIs which can really
be devastating
now UTI pathogenesis classically in
women we think of uh E coli coming from
a gut Reservoir to colonize the vagina
and then under the right circumstances
ascending from the vagina into the
bladder to cause a urinary tract
infection there are a lot of other
complicated mechanisms here but that's
the basic idea and so the vaginal
microbiome might be very important in
determining that intermediate step in
the middle here whether E coli is
capable of colonizing the vagina because
that's a key step in the pathway
ultimately leading to urinary tract
infection
now there have been some uh cohort
epidemiologic studies that suggest that
uh women with vasil lactobacilli are
less likely to have introital
colonization with E coli and less likely
to have an E coli UTI that was shown by
Houghton back in 1989.
and then an interesting study done by
Raz in the New England Journal in 1993
randomized post-menopausal women with
recurrent UTIs to either get
intravaginal estrogen or Placebo and
interestingly they found that women who
got the intravaginal estrogen were both
more likely to have lactobacilli
detected after the intravaginal estrogen
in the vaginal in vaginal swabs and also
less likely to have UTIs after the
intravaginal estrogen so perhaps in this
case the promotion of vaginal estrogen
uh sorry the promotion of vaginal
estrogen led to increase lactobacilli
which perhaps led to some protection
against UTIs but that's really an area
that needs a lot more research
there is some suggestion that perhaps
competitive binding just as with STIs
could be important in preventing E coli
from binding in the vagina and also
there are some in vitro studies that I
won't discuss in too much detail but
there's one by Guardian L here
um that show that in vitro equal I seem
to be inhibited by lactic acid and by
the supernatants uh produced by some uh
lactobacilli
so really I think this brings up the
question we've we've seen now that there
are these associations between having a
low lactobacillus vaginal microbiome or
bv-like state and an increased risk of
uh gonorrhea chlamydia trichomonas HPV
HIV and perhaps even urinary tract
infections though again that's an area
of uh research that needs more work
but I think there are a lot of
challenges
um here I think it really raises the
question could we actually optimize the
vaginal microbiome to prevent these
infections and improve Women's Health
this is a really exciting idea but again
there are a lot of very uh important
challenges along the way number one is
that bacterial vaginosis is very very
difficult to treat nearly 30 percent
recur within one month and 60 within 12
months after antibiotics part of that
may be that our tools at present are
very blunt so really all we have to give
is antibiotics and we essentially blast
the vaginal microbiome knock down the
levels of bv-associated bacteria but
really I think if you think about it
we'd want a way to put back some of the
healthy and protective lactobacilli as
well we don't have a great way to do
that yet at least not with our
commercially available treatments
additionally hormonal issues may be a
complicating Factor particularly in
post-menopausal women so if you just
don't have the estrogen there to support
the growth of lactobacilli perhaps just
treating with antibiotics isn't going to
do much so perhaps you need to
supplement with other things like that
intervaginal estrogen or maybe there are
other factors to consider and then
there's another very important issue the
contribution of sex partners
um so before women become sexually
active they don't really get bacterial
vaginosis
um studies treating male Partners to try
to reduce recurrent BV in the female
have not really resulted in an
improvement but there is this question
of whether there's an element of
reinfection associated with a sex
partner and so that may be a
complicating Factor when we're trying to
figure out how to optimize the vaginal
microbiome treat bacterial vaginosis and
put women into a lasting stable
lactobacillus domain
there have been some exciting
developments recently however
um there are a number of things to
consider but one I wanted to highlight
was a high profile pal paper that came
out in the New England Journal by Cohen
where they essentially randomized women
with BV to after getting treated with
antibiotics getting an intravaginal
probiotic of lactobacillus crespitis
versus a placebo and they treated them
for 12 weeks and at 12 weeks they saw
that in the lactobacillus crespitis
probiotic group there was a 30 percent
recurrence whereas there was a 45
recurrence of BV in the placebo group
and that was statistically significant
though that by 24 weeks it was not so
significant so I think uh only in the
sort of terrible world of recurrent BV
would we be excited about a 30
recurrence rate just at 12 weeks but I
think it is really very exciting and
interesting because it shows that as a
paradigm perhaps we can actually opt the
vaginal microbiome treat BV and then
perhaps in the long term improve some of
these outcomes and protect against your
genital infections in women
so again many challenges I think another
big challenge is really that BV
treatment it's not clear at this point
at exactly if treating with antibiotics
is optimal
um some women may have increases in
cytokines and inflammation the vaginal
micro environment there was at least one
study that suggested that though I think
more research is needed and then lastly
what is the right probiotic for the
right woman is that really uh the same
for every woman
um why should we think for example that
a probiotic strain of lactobacillus
crispatis developed and isolated from a
woman in the United States should be the
same strain that's optimal for a woman
in sub-Saharan Africa
um I think we need a lot more research
to really understand what is the right
probiotic or what is the right bacterial
strain what is the right vaginal
microbiome that's optimal for the right
woman
but I think again this really raises a
question of uh the promise of the future
and is that and that is really that
perhaps we'll be able to develop vaginal
microbiome-based Therapeutics that can
prevent your genital infections in women
and I think that's a very exciting
prospect
so I'll end there and I did want to say
some thank yous to Rebecca Brockman
Khalil ganum Jacques Ravel and Victoria
Hand up thank you